i bought a suit for this i thought it
was going to be on tv i'm such a [ __ ]
i am losing so much money right now and
i want everyone in america right now to
look at me
look at me smoking indoors
i didn't ask anybody i just did it what
are they gonna do kick me out before i
get the prize
now [ __ ] this is called leverage
our next presenters are two of the
funniest people in america
she stole the show on saturday night
live then went on to create write and
start her own show
30 rock he was a job in actor
career not going that well if i'm being
totally honest who
who got his big break when i cast him in
a remake
of a show that i created called the
office
he's now leaving that show and killing a
cash cow for both of us
please welcome the wonderful tina fey
and the ungrateful steve carrell
oh julia roberts you live next to me at
the beach you know that thanks for all
the visits
anyway i'm living about two blocks from
the broad never shows up come by and say
hello we're closer than two blocks i
have no lines julia just not
anyway and the winner uh the grammy goes
to
natalia lafocay
[Music]
sorry i will accept on behalf of her if
i butchered a name i'm sorry
thank you very much i'm very excited to
be here you know and i was asked to
host the svs this year yeah that's my
name esme
when i was asked to host the espys this
year folks i said yes
immediately for one reason and one
reason only
this show has interns
[Applause]
it wasn't the only epic movie once upon
a time in hollywood nearly three hours
long
leonardo dicaprio attended the premiere
and by the end his date was too old for
him
all right hey how many uh feminists are
like going nuts how why is this this
white male doing all this latino stuff
uh and the grammy goes to grupo niche
hey nishi
you know when i was asked to host the
canadian screen awards
i called my good friend chris rock and i
said to him
i've got some great news chris i'm going
to canada and he said
i've got some great news too i'm hosting
the oscars what are you doing in canada
and i said you know visiting some family
friends
no one cares about movers anymore no one
goes to cinema no one really watches
network tv
everyone's watching netflix this show
should just be me coming out going well
done netflix you win
everything good night but no no we gotta
drag out for three hours
you could binge watch the entire first
season of afterlife
instead of watching this show that
that's a show about a man
who wants to kill himself because his
wife dies of cancer
and it's still more fun than this okay
spoiler alert um season two is on the
way so in the end
he obviously didn't kill himself just
like jeffrey epstein
shut up i know he's your friend but i
don't care
[Applause]
sorry i wasn't listening to that one i'm
going to butcher this and the grammy
goes to
hilder gunnar duter for joker
yeah the nuggets are having a bad year
this year man matter of fact they're
making a film about the team
they had a pretty catchy title it's uh
black men can't jump either
one hollywood publication said that me
hosting would mean
that some film stars would stay away for
fear of being made fun of
as if film starts to stay away from the
chance of winning a golden globe
particularly if their film company has
already paid for it
mr don prickles
mr chairman ladies and gentlemen
why did they stand was it jewish holiday
no
because you're a legend don because
you're you that was very sweet of you
folks to stand
next time just leave a check by the door
i think
talking of the walking dead
congratulations to hugh hefner
who uh is
getting married at the age of 84 to 24
year old beauty crystal harris
um when she was asked why she was
marrying him she said because he lied
about his age
he told me he was 94. oh come on
um don't worry
hold out and just just don't look at it
when you touch it
this is great oj simpson jury right
there in the front
like my gentleman's laughing it's a
little hula
the teleprompter is sort of flashing oh
really because it's a hot show let's
read these funny looks
let's let's read these funny lines they
wrote for us okay
talking of all you perverts it was a big
year
it was a big year for pedophile movies
um
surviving r kelly leaving neverland
two popes shut up shut up i don't care i
don't care
and there's charles woodson how about
that i want a season he had
[Applause]
great manny he became the first
defensive player to win the heisman
trophy and congratulations charles
that is something that no one can ever
take away from you
unless you kill your wife and a waiter
in which case
[Music]
and um i got to be honest like uh i
don't know much about writers
you know i used to think you guys were a
bunch of nerds
who couldn't hold up your end of the
conversation you know with
strange shoes
i did lots of big celebrities here
tonight i mean legends
icons yeah look at this table alone uh
al pacino robert de niro
baby yoda oh that's that's joe pesci
sorry
um he just backstaged a lot of
celebrities back there man i was talking
to jerry jones you know the cowboys
owner and
he's disappointed obviously yeah
well he's a good guy though man he's
talking about rebuilding the team you
know
and he told me he says we have to get
back to what made us a championship team
strippers and crack
it was a big year for 3d movies toy
story
despicable me tron seems like everything
this year was three-dimensional
except the characters in the tourist um
i i feel bad about that joke i
no no i'll tell you why i'm jumping on
the bandwagon because i haven't even
seen the tourist
who has um but no it must be good
because it's nominated so shut up okay
and i'd like to quash this ridiculous
rumor going around
that the only reason the taurus was
nominated was so the hollywood foreign
press could hang out with johnny depp
and angelina jolie
that is that is rubbish that is not the
only reason
they also accepted bribes let's